[MUSIC PLAYING]
BRAD GREENHILL:
I went to college
at University of Michigan.
And I got into cooking
when I was there.
I cooked professionally after I
graduated for about four years,
five years.
And then was feeling
burned out, wasn't sure
if that's what I wanted to do,
so I went back to technology.
I have an engineering
degree from Michigan.
So I started a web
development company.
I also did graphic design, and
so very familiar with Google.
And my partner, actually, he's
over in the Madison building,
my old business partner.
He started Quickly.
I don't know if anyone's
familiar with here.
Maybe.
Maybe not.
Anyway, so after I started
that, I got interested in--
kind of rediscovered my love and
passion for food, and started--
they weren't called
pop-ups then.
I just started hosting
dinners in Ann Arbor.
Usually, there was a bakery.
We'd run out.
Or I'd have them at my
house and stuff like that,
and started getting
a huge following,
and had a massive email list.
So I would announce, oh,
I'm doing a dinner here.
And people would buy
tickets and show up.
And so I started looking into
opening a restaurant in Ann
Arbor, and found it to be
difficult. In the meantime,
opportunity started
presenting itself in Detroit.
And I was spending
more time in Detroit.
And there is a lot different
energy between the two towns.
Like, everyone in Ann Arbor
was like, oh, you should really
open a restaurant.
OK, that's great, but I need
help, supporters, backers
to do it.
Whereas people in
Detroit were like,
hey, let's open a restaurant.
And so it was a
different sort of--
SPEAKER: It was
almost [INAUDIBLE]
BRAD GREENHILL: Yeah,
like a different attitude.
And for someone like myself,
with an entrepreneurial spirit
who's never really
had a corporate job
or a job, really--
I've always just started
my own businesses,
pretty much since I
graduated, outside
of occasional restaurant work--
that sort of energy
and spirit really
attracted me to the city.
So I just kind of took the
jump and moved to Detroit
and did pop-ups there, and
then food truck, and then
another pop-up, and then
finally the restaurant.
SPEAKER: That's
super interesting.
And I know that where
the location is now--
we'll get to this in a minute,
about the rebirth of that--
you started as a
food truck for Two
James, which is directly
across the street.
So tell us a little
bit, before we
get to Christina
and your background,
about the connection
there, with Two James.
BRAD GREENHILL: So my
partner in the restaurant,
Courtney, had this idea,
let's get a food truck.
And I was like, you know, OK.
I guess so.
Why not?
At the time, I was transitioning
out of doing web development
and pretty much doing
pop-ups full-time.
And I was actively working
on opening a restaurant,
but nothing had really
materialized quite yet.
And so we're like, yeah,
let's get the food truck.
You know, she wanted it
because she did events,
so she thought it
would be cool to be
able to have a truck at
her events to serve food
or whatever.
And I was just interested
in cooking all the time.
So we bought a truck,
with the intention
of sort of setting
up in different spots
all around town.
But about a couple of
months after we bought it,
it broke down.
The axle broke.
And so we were storing it
right next door to Two James,
because that was the--
there was a restaurant
finally going in there,
but that was the spot that I
was in talks with about possibly
opening a restaurant there.
And my good friends
had started Two James.
So we had planned on
serving there already.
And then we were
just stuck there
once we broke down, because
we didn't have the money
to get it fixed.
SPEAKER: That's awesome.
BRAD GREENHILL: Yeah, it was a
very, highly illegal operation.
SPEAKER: Operation.
BRAD GREENHILL: Yeah.
And we used to have to
have a drill if the health
department came, because
we were broke down,
which is like a big no-no,
and we were in this garage.
But we were selling so much
food that we were like,
spilling out of the truck.
Like, the truck
could not contain it.
So we're in this garage, and we
had like, a prep refrigerator,
and these prep tables in
there, and next to that
was a [INAUDIBLE] and a salt
truck for in a snow plow.
And it was just like, you can't
make it up-- only in Detroit.
SPEAKER: Only in Detroit,
I was just about to say.
BRAD GREENHILL: Only In
Detroit, in this specific era,
could that have happened.
So you know, so
we'd run this drill.
If the Health Department
came, shut the door,
and oh, they're not here today.
And we kind of got away
with it, because our truck
was licensed in Royal Oak.
And so it didn't really fall
under the Detroit jurisdiction.
And we just had to,
like every six months,
find a way to get
it to Royal Oak
to get it reinspected,
to get the thing.
CHRISTINA PONSARAN:
I've got to say,
I learn more and more as I
hear you tell these stories,
like more stuff that
I would have never
expected to have happened.
And it's just--
BRAD GREENHILL: Right.
The truck was--
CHRISTINA PONSARAN:
It's terrifying.
BRAD GREENHILL: Yeah.
The truck was a terrifyingly
awesome experience.
What was kind of funny about it
is a lot of people thought what
we were doing was intentional.
And we were just like,
trying to make it happen.
You know, we were just
trying to find a way
to make food and
sell it and pay rent
and all this kind of stuff.
But we had these people
come in from Chicago,
and, oh, we heard
about this food truck,
and it's like, very
authentic Thai experience.
And so they came,
and they were like,
you know, we were just out
of [INAUDIBLE] yesterday,
and honestly, this experience,
it's like you're in Thailand.
Like, there was even a
rat that scurried by.
SPEAKER: Oh no!
BRAD GREENHILL: And like,
all this kind of stuff.
And I was like, yeah,
it's real, authentic!
[LAUGHTER]
CHRISTINA PONSARAN:
That's our mascot.
BRAD GREENHILL: Yeah.
Yeah.
SPEAKER: Well, it was
interesting the first time
that I went to the old
restaurant, which was Katoi.
BRAD GREENHILL: Yeah
SPEAKER: I would say the
building is very unassuming.
And I don't mean that in
a negative way at all.
But I actually thought
I was in the wrong place
the first time I pulled up to--
CHRISTINA PONSARAN:
It's a common thing.
BRAD GREENHILL: That was
very much intentional.
SPEAKER: OK.
Tell us a little
bit more about that,
because it is--
the location makes
sense, the story about being at
Two James as a food truck that
is not mobile.
But then looking
for space close by--
because you obviously
found a market that
was really into your food--
to look directly
across the street,
it looks like a white cinder
block, no-window space,
also very small, is
very interesting.
So tell us about that.
BRAD GREENHILL: So
when we were running
the truck, our third
partner, Philip, we met.
He had just bought that
property across the street
and wanted to put
a restaurant in.
And he had kind
of a lame concept.
And so we were like,
hey, let's just
do the food truck concept
in the restaurant.
And sort of the big thing that
we both kind of wanted out
of it was we wanted it to have
like a rabbit hole effect,
so that there's just
this white building,
and maybe there's a
sign, maybe there's not,
or there's a red
light out front.
Or it's just very unassuming.
But then when you walk
in, it's like you're
into this whole new
universe, kind of.
So that was kind of what
we wanted to do with that.
And ultimately, we put a
little neon sign out front.
But we pretty much kept
the old building intact,
up to the false door of the
old entrance and everything.
But we never-- we were just kind
of like, we're in such a rush
to get open, like,
we never landscaped
it, never finished anything.
There was just like,
dirt piles outside,
and for like three months, there
was a giant hole in the ground,
because they were
excavating something.
And so it never got done.
And we started working
on the addition.
And then that's when
the fire happened.
SPEAKER: It is exactly that,
because when you walk inside,
you're like, wait,
what just happened?
I thought I was walking into
almost an abandoned building
for--
not anymore.
I think in Takoi, you've
done a lot of transformation
on the outside.
But I love that you kept
the inside of Katoi,
of Takoi, because
it's so beautiful.
I've heard people
compare it to being
in South Beach or SoHo, or
some of the more vibrant cities
around the world,
than even in Detroit.
But what did you model
the inside after?
BRAD GREENHILL: I think
a lot of the inside
was sort of, before we
opened the first time, was
a little bit kind of improvved.
We had a sort of aesthetic
that was planned,
which was the bar in the
front, the dining room.
And so it was kind of
like layers of an onion,
like bookends.
Like, you come in, and
there's one experience,
and then there's
another experience,
and then there's the
kitchen experience.
And the polycarbonate
was always planned.
But our architect,
he's amazing, but he
can be, for lack of a
better term, a little stiff.
And he wanted a specific
warm light behind the panels.
And so when we're
building it, Philip,
who is our other partner,
he is a little bit more
irreverent and excited.
And he was like, no,
let's have colored lights.
And so like when Ish was
around, we kind of like
took all his work and like,
oh, no, let's do this.
And all the stuff that he would
never allow, we kind of did.
And it took on its own
personality, everything
from like, there was a crown
of lights around the building,
and stuff like that.
SPEAKER: It's so inspiring.
And maybe someday when people
are in another city in the US,
they'll say, oh, this is
just like being in Detroit,
because you've
given us something
really cool to go off of.
BRAD GREENHILL: Well,
we wanted a restaurant
that you could only
have in Detroit.
SPEAKER: In Detroit.
Yeah.
It feels like that.
BRAD GREENHILL: And so keeping
the inside, no painting
on the cinder block,
and keeping it all old,
and keeping the graffiti in
there and stuff like that,
was all very parts of it.
CHRISTINA PONSARAN: It's
also really interesting
to note the fact that even
for Ish, our architect,
this was the first restaurant
he'd ever designed.
BRAD GREENHILL: Yeah.
CHRISTINA PONSARAN: So
you have four people--
I mean, three partners who've
never had a restaurant before,
brick and mortar, and this
is what they come up with.
And another interesting
thing to note
about the interior
of the restaurant
is that the booths
and the tables
are all extremely low-set.
BRAD GREENHILL: Yeah.
CHRISTINA PONSARAN:
What did you say?
It was Japanese inspired?
BRAD GREENHILL: Yeah.
And that was very much
intentional by the architect.
He wanted everything to
be on the same plane,
and low-set, which is sort of
an Eastern philosophy of eating,
being close to the ground.
You know, a lot of
Eastern cultures,
people sit on the ground
or at very low tables.
And so that was all
very intentional.
Ish, he thinks about things
that I would never think about.
SPEAKER: That's a
good partner to have.
BRAD GREENHILL: Great.
SPEAKER: Well, Christina,
I want to give you a chance
to tell us a little bit
about your background, too,
and how you came
into the restaurant.
CHRISTINA PONSARAN: Ooh.
Well, I'm originally
from Chicago.
I went to school in New York.
And after school, I thought I
wanted to do market research.
I was a business analyst
for the first two years.
And then it wasn't
really fitting me.
And then I wanted to
go back into education.
That's kind of what
I studied originally.
Went to Spain, lived
abroad, taught there.
Still, something wasn't
exactly pulling at my heart.
I found my way in Philadelphia,
in part for a boy,
in part for a job.
I will confess that.
And that's actually where
I got my start in food.
And so I just needed to
hit the reset button.
I needed to do something where
I would find immediate results.
I missed having a job that
had some physicality to it,
some instant results.
And so I got my start
in a really tiny cafe.
And then pretty much
from there on out,
for the past eight and
a half, nine years,
only worked for startups.
I've only worked for
small businesses.
So from that, I loved being
able to wear many hats
and just try on so
many different roles.
I mean, in many
ways, I was manager.
But I would also
be doing payroll,
or I would also be
doing the marketing,
or I'd be doing
the social media.
So I think, similar
to Brad, I really
enjoyed having that
entrepreneurial spirit
and being able to work with food
and work within a community.
And in Philadelphia,
people are great.
Philly's a great town.
And I think I came in when
they were having their food
renaissance.
And that really kept me
inspired and kept me interested.
And so the last
place I worked at,
I was running three different
locations-- one in New York,
one in a Whole Foods, and our
brick and mortar location,
which we're a hummus place.
And then next door to me,
actually shared a kitchen
with another restaurant that was
part of our restaurant group.
And I met Drew Pompa, who is the
original bar director of Takoi.
He had known Brad and Courtney
and Philip for quite some time.
And he was telling me back in,
it was only May, he was saying,
I'm thinking about going back.
I'm like, but you've only
been here for six months.
Like, you haven't even seen
what Philliy has to offer.
And he started telling
me more and more
about what his job was,
what his position was.
Ironically, his restaurant had
thrown a fundraiser for Katoi
when it burned down.
So that was only
the first instance
that I had heard
of the restaurant.
And so everyone in the
restaurant community
in Philadelphia got
together and raised a couple
thousand dollars for a
restaurant that none of us
had ever been to.
So there's a lot of camaraderie,
a lot of interest in this place
already.
He was telling me that they were
looking for a general manager.
And I said, I'm pretty
happy with my job.
And then he managed to convince
Philip and Brad to fly out
to meet me.
And I thought that
was so incredible.
That's so impressive.
You know, only very serious
people, or crazy people,
will do that.
So we had a wonderful
conversation.
And I was a little intrigued.
And I didn't feel like I could
make a decision from there.
Within two weeks' time, I
booked a flight to Detroit.
It was a 24-hour trip.
I met Courtney,
the third partner.
And she whisked me around town.
And she was like,
the velvet glove
that made the decision
so much easier.
She introduced me to so
many different people.
And I began to see what
Drew had been talking about,
what all this intrigue
and all this excitement
and opportunity in Detroit
was, through Courtney's eyes,
and obviously through
the rest of the team.
So within a week,
I made my decision
to move and completely
try something new.
And that's how I ended
up at this family.
BRAD GREENHILL:
Yeah, little known--
she doesn't even know
this fact right now, but--
CHRISTINA PONSARAN: Oh no.
BRAD GREENHILL: When we first--
Philip sent me out to
Philly to go talk to Drew,
to gauge his interest in
coming back to Detroit.
SPEAKER: To win him back.
BRAD GREENHILL: Yeah, to win
him back, bring him back.
And this was when
we were rebuilding.
And I met Christina
on that trip.
And I said to my
girlfriend at the time,
I think I'm going
to try and bring
her back to be general manager.
She didn't even know that.
CHRISTINA PONSARAN:
Oh, I didn't know that.
BRAD GREENHILL: The seed
was planted early on.
CHRISTINA PONSARAN:
All the meanwhile, I
was feeding you food,
and making it nice.
SPEAKER: Yeah, that's a lot
of wooing of you, Christina.
BRAD GREENHILL: I know.
CHRISTINA PONSARAN: Yeah.
BRAD GREENHILL: The plotting
didn't come till after we left.
CHRISTINA PONSARAN: OK.
BRAD GREENHILL: But
I was like, huh.
I had this idea.
It was like, in my head.
And then Drew was like, you
know, I think I have someone.
And I was like, oh,
is it Christina?
And he was like, oh, yeah.
And I was like, yeah, all right.
SPEAKER: Well, we're not here
to promote any other restaurants
in Detroit, but I'm so curious.
What was that
moment that you had?
Was it a bunch of
other places that you
went and saw that there was a
really vibrant food scene here?
Or was there an
actual moment that you
thought you could make
Detroit your culinary home?
CHRISTINA PONSARAN: Yeah, you
know, I think a lot of it--
I had been to Detroit a
couple of times before,
had some really great meals.
I have a few friends
that are from the city.
But I think it was more
about the opportunity
to work with Brad, the
opportunity to work with Philip
and Courtney, and
just the way that they
felt about this
business and everything
that they thought
that it could be.
I'm someone that has
always chosen opportunities
based on the people
that I get to work with.
If I get to have a
really good team,
Lord knows how far you can go.
So I mean, I don't know if
it was Brad's anecdotes,
or if it was
Philip's unbounded--
BRAD GREENHILL: Now
she's like, super
annoyed with me all the time.
CHRISTINA PONSARAN: Yeah.
[LAUGHTER]
I feel like we're
on Sally Jesse's--
SPEAKER: That happens
in good teams, though.
That's a really important
thing here for us at Google,
too, is you spend most of
your life, actually, working.
CHRISTINA PONSARAN: Right.
SPEAKER: Working with
the people that you
work with is a really major
part of successful teams.
So it's exciting to hear.
I want to talk about the
food for a minute, too.
So I don't know
if you know this,
but I was at the restaurant
on Saturday night.
And I thought it was
really interesting,
because I knew I was
going to get a great meal.
But it's very much
an experience.
I hope that that's a
favorable adjective--
CHRISTINA PONSARAN: 100%.
SPEAKER: --that you use.
When our server
came to our table,
she actually said, I'll be
your guide for the night.
And all four of us at the table,
one a lot more culinary-wise
than the three of us, we
noticed that right away.
And we asked her about
it when she came back.
And she said, one
thing about Takoi
is that we hope to awaken
all five of the senses.
So we don't want
you to just have
a sweet and savory experience.
We want it to be everything.
Can you talk to us a little bit
about that, that notion that we
have servers who
are more so guides
that take us through
our experience at Takoi?
CHRISTINA PONSARAN:
Yeah, absolutely.
I think, just in
terms of nomenclature,
I mean, the idea of server
and waiter is very antiquated.
And I think for us, we want to
have a level of inclusivity.
We want people to
feel seen and heard,
and this is a safe place.
So the idea of having
someone be a guide
is a lot more accurate
of what the experience
is for anyone new or a
veteran that's coming in.
And so many of the
foods and ingredients
are incredibly
unfamiliar to people.
So the idea of a person
who is super knowledgeable,
who is super passionate, is able
to walk you through and help
you curate the
choices of what you're
going to be experiencing--
I mean so much of
what Brad's cooking is
is bold, flavorful, loud,
spicy, things on the extreme.
So depending on what
it is that people need
and what people want,
if you're a newbie who
doesn't necessarily want to have
something that's super spicy,
you know, certainly.
Someone will be able to
provide something for you.
There is something for
everyone on that menu, which
is super exciting.
SPEAKER: The connection back
to technology or social media
or however you want to say it is
very interesting, because when
you do look at your menu online,
there are a lot of things
that, to the novice person,
you're not familiar with.
I'm going to say it
wrong, but the branzino,
the full fish that comes out.
One of our guests was like,
I've never heard of that before.
So I went to YouTube and I
watched a 10-minute video
on how to eat a whole
fish, because there
is an actual technique.
So talk to us a
little bit about how
you guys are using technology,
social media, or what
channels you're finding success
growing the business with.
BRAD GREENHILL: Well, I think
we use technology every day.
And I think that we'll continue
to use it more and more.
Everything from our
reservation ticketing system,
it's called Tock,
so it's online.
And rather than-- we
don't have reservations
in the traditional
sense, but you
can buy a ticket to come to
the restaurant with a group,
and then-- so it's similar
to going to a concert
or something like that.
So that's one example.
And of course, there's
Instagram and Facebook
and stuff like that.
But everything from
spreadsheets to--
I think we only have scratched
the surface on how much we
can use technology.
CHRISTINA PONSARAN: Absolutely.
I think there's a
lot more that we
can do to maximize,
especially once we
start delving more into video.
Brad always says, he
never wants to tell people
how to eat their food.
BRAD GREENHILL: Right.
CHRISTINA PONSARAN: But I think,
you know, a lot of times people
will reference-- how do people
make decisions on where they're
going to eat for a weekend?
They're going to go to Yelp.
They're going to go to Google.
And they're to go to Instagram.
And so with all
those things, people,
we rely so heavily
on those visual cues
and those visual choices.
And by bolstering
up those pieces,
it allows for
people to understand
what they can expect.
I mean, for me, I didn't
have the opportunity
to visit the restaurant
before I decided to move.
I didn't have the opportunity
to even taste the food.
So in many ways, I was
coming in as a consumer.
I was coming in as like,
a brand new person.
And so from what I had
gleaned, based on social media,
based on everything
that I had read,
was a lot of
important information.
And I think the more
that we translate
our story and our narrative
that way, the more powerful
it can be.
SPEAKER: Yeah.
We are in an environment where
sight, sound, and motion is now
cost of entry.
So it's more than
the Instagram's
of the world, where you have
these beautiful images of food.
It's video.
And it's something that we talk
a lot about with our customers
here at Google.
It's kind of, if
you don't have it,
you're not on a
consideration list.
BRAD GREENHILL: Right.
SPEAKER: So that's interesting.
What would be, if you
had endless budgets,
marketing budgets to produce
some crazy video, what would be
your dream video that would--
not an anthem, per se.
But is it how to
eat a whole fish?
Or is it something
else that you would
want to use to promote
the restaurant?
BRAD GREENHILL: Like, you mean
if I had my own Netflix show?
SPEAKER: Or anything.
Would you create your
own Netflix show?
Anything.
BRAD GREENHILL: No.
Well, I think it
would start with sort
of some how-tos,
educational sort of things
on how some of the
food is prepared.
And not necessarily
how you eat it,
but how it's presented,
and sort of culture
and history around that.
We use a lot of
different techniques
that aren't used in a
lot of other kitchens.
Most places are French-based.
So a lot of people come work
for me, and they're like,
this doesn't make sense.
This is like, the exact
opposite of everything
that I've been taught.
So I think that would be sort of
the start, sort of the process
and what is behind the food,
because everything we make
is from scratch.
And there's different
pastes and fermentations
and stuff like that.
And so to me, as
kind of like a nerd,
that's what I would be into.
I would want to see
the video of, oh,
how do they ferment that?
Or how do they make that?
So I think that's kind
of where it would start,
and kind of evolve from there.
But maybe Christina has
some different ideas.
CHRISTINA PONSARAN: Yeah, no.
I think that's
absolutely important.
I think so much of what
the experience is at Takoi
is encouraging
people to take risks.
Like you said, the exterior
is very, in many ways,
unassuming and uninviting.
And what is it?
Like, how do you encourage
people to take risks?
And then how do you
then reward them
for being awesome and
trying something new
and trying something that they
never expected they would like?
So I think getting
people to understand
some of the base
of the ingredients,
but also profiling the
different spaces within.
Going back to the interiors,
we also have a DJ room.
We also have-- which
is an annex, which
is a waiting room, which is
a threshold into the patio.
So there are so many different
features to the space
that are really interesting and
very complex, but ultimately,
a place where people can
find themselves within.
I think it's allowing for
people to find themselves
within our world
that can make it
a really wonderful experience.
SPEAKER: One thing
that I think is
kind of the elephant
in the room,
so I'll let you guys
take this question
and answer it however
you want, but there
is a lot of speculation around
the fire, around what happened,
and a lot of fans who, here
and even in this room, who
had been to Katoi several
times and were shocked when
the fire happened, and
the delay between Katoi
and now what's Takoi.
So feel free to address
that however you want.
BRAD GREENHILL: Yeah.
Well, I was in Thailand at the
time that the fire happened.
Luckily-- yeah.
SPEAKER: Yeah, it wasn't you.
BRAD GREENHILL:
Yeah, it wasn't me.
Luckily, it was at the
tail end of my trip,
so I didn't have a
tough decision to make.
I was leaving the next day.
But yeah.
There's always been a lot of
speculation about the fire.
But basically what happened
was, like I was saying,
we were building a
new addition to the--
we had put on another
shipping container
and the bar was going to
extend out to the right side.
And then there was going to
be a little secret garden
on the side patio.
And they had just put in a glass
screen door, which is now still
on the shipping container
that's in a different spot.
But what they failed to
take into consideration
was that that screen
door was completely
shielded off from Michigan
and also from 17th.
So anyone could easily come
and not be seen from that side.
So what happened was,
there was a series
of break-ins that night.
The first one was at
Nemo's down the street.
And someone went in, smashed the
window, stole a bunch of booze.
And then a little bit
later that night, there
was a break-in at our place.
So someone had smashed
that screen window,
went into that
shipping container,
and then broke the window
to get into the restaurant.
And again, no one's going to
see this or hear it happening.
Went in and stole pretty
much all the booze
within arm's reach, and
ran out the back door.
They found one of the
bags of booze out there.
And we have a little tip safe
up at the counter, where,
actually, the fire started.
They tried to-- they
smashed it open with an axe
that we had by our smoker
that we used to split wood
to put it into the smoker.
So it was someone who
was familiar with--
who had walked around
in the neighborhood,
to know that that wood
splitter was there,
to know that that
entrance had literally,
two days before the fire,
just been installed.
So as someone-- yeah,
someone in the area.
And then they started a fire
at the host stand, which
why they did, we don't know.
The speculation that we
have is at the host stand
was where we have
the stereo equipment.
And so our thought
was that they probably
thought that that was a camera
system, because it's not clear
that it's stereo.
And so that was
all wood encased.
So they started a fire there
and it ran out the back door.
There was a witness.
There was a suspect.
And I believe that there
was someone brought
into custody that said that
they broke in but didn't
start the fire.
But there's no proof linking
them to the whole thing.
But--
SPEAKER: It's still
an unsolved mystery.
BRAD GREENHILL: It's an unsolved
mystery, as far as I know.
I haven't checked in
on it for a long time.
You know, right
afterwards, you're
like, you want to
catch the person.
And then you start realizing
that more than likely,
the person who did
this was like--
there's no-- the punishment
doesn't fit the crime, kind of.
Like, what-- it's not going
to bring the restaurant back.
This guy's life
already is not good.
You know, he's probably
homeless, alcoholic.
In a lot of ways, this is--
if he goes to jail, his life
will probably be better.
You know?
SPEAKER: Yeah.
BRAD GREENHILL: Debatable, but--
Trials and
tribulations, for sure.
So you reopened in
December of 2017?
Or was it even--
BRAD GREENHILL: August.
SPEAKER: Oh, it was August.
Excuse--
BRAD GREENHILL: August.
SPEAKER: Yeah.
And we were all thrilled
to see you reopen.
So talk to us a little bit
about maybe the future.
What is Takoi-- is it going to
grow beyond the space it's in
now?
Or any other plans for 2.0?
CHRISTINA PONSARAN: Yeah,
there's a couple things.
I mean, we finally--
we've been open, what, now?
Six months?
BRAD GREENHILL: Yeah.
CHRISTINA PONSARAN:
And we finally hit
our stride, and still dealing
with crazy busy Saturdays,
like the one that you were at.
And we're trying to figure
out more ways how we
can offer different features.
So Brad is doing, once a month,
these special green room dinner
series.
They're like small,
intimate dinners
where he's cooking food that has
never been on the menu before.
They're completely one-off.
And they're inspired by
different regions of Thailand.
So this past one that he did
was southern Thai cuisine,
and the one before that
was northern Thai cuisine.
BRAD GREENHILL: Yeah.
CHRISTINA PONSARAN:
In addition to that,
what is different from
1.0 is that we now
have DJs that regularly play.
So there's Wednesdays
for happy hour,
and then Friday and
Saturday nights.
So we're definitely going to
build out that as a feature
and have some great acts
during movement, hopefully.
Just a lot-- we're going
to be opening a patio.
BRAD GREENHILL:
Patio season, yeah.
SPEAKER: Plans for a
patio, that's exciting.
BRAD GREENHILL: The patio--
when we opened,
wisely, we decided
not to open the patio also.
That gives us a
little bit of time
to figure out what
we want to do.
But yeah.
We're going to have food
out on the patio that's
a little bit different
from what you get inside.
It's going to be more, kind
of as if you were visiting
a street stall in Thailand
or something like that,
so very kind of street food.
And it's going to be cool.
And then from there, there
isn't plans for a Takoi 2.0,
but we are, same team, opening
a restaurant called Magnet.
We'll be opening in August.
SPEAKER: Where will
Magnet be located?
BRAD GREENHILL: It's in
Detroit, Grand River and Warren.
So our partner Philip owns
some property over there.
So Takoi is in an old garage.
This is is an old radiator shop.
SPEAKER: Wow.
BRAD GREENHILL:
So there is like--
I think it'll very much
be the sister restaurant,
but we won't be the same.
Like, you'll know it's
by the same people.
SPEAKER: Totally different menu?
BRAD GREENHILL: Totally
different style of food.
SPEAKER: Totally
different style.
What would the
style of Magnet be?
BRAD GREENHILL:
Without going into it--
SPEAKER: Oh yeah, sorry.
Has this been announced?
CHRISTINA PONSARAN:
Good question.
SPEAKER: Is this your
official announcement?
BRAD GREENHILL: This
could be, a little bit.
SPEAKER: Oh, nice.
Yes.
BRAD GREENHILL: I won't get into
specific regions of the world,
but the whole kitchen is
going to be fire-driven.
So it's wood-fired
grill, wood-fired oven,
wood-fired plancha, coal pits.
So the whole kitchen is
all based on wood fire,
live wood-fire cooking.
So that informs it quite a bit.
And I think the
other aspect of it,
it's going to be very
plant focused, so heavy
vegetarian, vegan influence.
From there, I think the rest,
the world is our palate.
I think more what
we're kind of going
for is creating a, for
lack of a better term,
Detroit food, like something
that could only come from here,
based on what's around
us and stuff like that.
SPEAKER: Something other
than Faygo Redpop and Better
Made potato chips and
Buddy's Pizza, which we love.
Those are great.
BRAD GREENHILL: All great,
but we don't have to--
SPEAKER: We need a new palate.
BRAD GREENHILL: It doesn't mean
it's Detroit just because you
braise your ribs in Rock and
Rye or crumble Better Made chips
on it.
SPEAKER: Where does the
name Magnet come from?
BRAD GREENHILL: So
the former business
that was there was called
Magnet Radiator Works.
SPEAKER: Cool.
BRAD GREENHILL: And so when we
got the building, I was like,
that's a cool name.
And so we started thinking
about, creatively,
what's the concept of a magnet?
And a magnet is something that
sort of attracts and pulls
people or items together.
And so that's kind
of loosely the theme
going behind the
food, is the idea
of what are the foods
near us, around us,
that we're sort of
attracted to, and what
are the foods that are kind
of attracted to each other?
So that's sort of the
basis of creatively
how I'm approaching it.
SPEAKER: What's your soft
launch date or target open date?
Do you have one?
BRAD GREENHILL:
That I can't say.
SPEAKER: Is that a tough one?
BRAD GREENHILL:
Sometime in the summer.
SPEAKER: OK, great.
BRAD GREENHILL: Yeah.
Probably on the later side.
SPEAKER: Great.
Well, that's exciting.
BRAD GREENHILL: Don't
hold me to August.
SPEAKER: We'll be
looking forward to that.
I want to allow time if
there's any questions.
It looks like we've got one
over here to start with.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Thanks, guys, for coming in.
We really appreciate it.
Takoi is definitely my favorite
spot in all of Detroit,
hands down.
So thank you.
One comment, and two questions--
sorry to be that guy.
The comment is I
think it's awesome
that with this new
Magnet restaurant,
that you're not shying
away from having
open fire in your restaurant.
BRAD GREENHILL: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: It's almost
like an homage to Katoi.
So I like that.
BRAD GREENHILL:
Well, the irony is
that we're going
to have open fire,
and then the design
that Ish has come up
with for the whole front
of the house is all wood.
So you know--
CHRISTINA PONSARAN:
We'll see what happens.
AUDIENCE: Fingers crossed.
BRAD GREENHILL: Be very careful.
AUDIENCE: Two questions.
One's real-- well,
not simple, but I'm
just curious why Thai
was the selected food
choice for Katoi, now Takoi.
And then two, if you could
maybe expand a little bit--
I've heard the story
from Courtney--
on the transition
period, what happened
between the fire at Katoi
and the reopening of Takoi,
in terms of keeping
all of your employees
on and bouncing around to make
sure that there was always
something to do.
And I also like the
story about the rally
of all of the restaurants,
not just around Detroit,
but around a lot of the Midwest
and even to the East Coast,
that kind of showed support
to raise money for you guys
to keep you moving.
BRAD GREENHILL: Well, I'll
start with the first question,
why Thai.
There's really no
great answer to it.
It was a philosophy
and style of food
that I just found
myself, probably
about eight to 10
years ago, migrating
towards without really knowing.
The concepts of sweet and
sour, salty, savory, spicy, I
started incorporating
heavily into sort
of my Italian
Mediterranean cooking I
was doing at the time.
And around that time is when I
started exploring Asian markets
and discovered fish
sauce and all this,
and started really studying.
And I'm always a curious
cook, so I probably
have 400 or 500 cookbooks.
So like, I'm always trying
to learn the next thing.
And this was just what
I sort of migrated to.
And so when-- but I
had an issue always
being known as the Italian
guy, or the Mediterranean guy.
And so I would be doing
these Thai dishes,
but labeling it on my menu
as like, Italian food,
kind of renaming it based on
the ingredients that were in it.
And so finally, when Courtney
decided do the food truck
and asked me about
it, I was like,
if we're doing a
food truck, this
is when I'm just
going to switch over
and just come at food completely
from a Thai, Southeast
Asian perspective, rather than
sprinkling that into the food
that I currently made.
And the nature of
the food truck,
being street food
and stuff like that,
felt like the natural jump-off
point to doing Thai full-time.
Now, with going into Magnet,
it's like how am I going to--
I don't know that
I can fully go back
to doing a different style of
food, because I'm warped from--
once you go Thai,
you don't go back.
[LAUGHTER]
And but it'll be a
lot of fun revisiting
sort of some food
I cooked before,
with new knowledge
and a new palate,
and bringing sort of some of
that dynamic boldness of Thai
cuisine into something that
may be more Mediterranean
or Italian or Middle Eastern or
something like that, or Indian.
It's always just trying
to find new flavors
and expanding my
knowledge as well as
what we're feeding guests.
Yeah.
And then second question--
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
The second question
was the process
that happened between
Katoi and Takoi.
BRAD GREENHILL: Yeah.
So a lot happened
in between that.
So the fire happened.
And I got back, and the
first thing you think
is like, I have 42 employees
who don't have income,
don't have a job.
What are we going to do?
And luckily, the community,
being as awesome as it is,
rallied.
And there was fundraisers,
seemingly like every day,
everywhere.
And so we used
that money to give
to all the employees
a little stipend
until they could find
temporary new work,
because we knew we
couldn't keep everyone on.
So we basically kept
like, a management team
and some few others,
like a core group
that we employed throughout
the duration of the closure.
So on my end, I started
doing what I did before
and organizing pop-ups all over
the place-- so Motor City Wine,
and we did one at Mabel Gray,
Grey Ghost, Selden Standard.
And it also just
happened to correspond
with the opening of
a place called Frame
in Hazel Park, which their
concept was having prolonged
residences for guest chefs.
And so they were
just about to open,
so it worked out perfectly.
We were there for three months.
And we did dinners
three days a week--
or yeah, two seatings
three days a week.
And that kept my
team pretty nimble.
We were working on
stuff that whole time.
SPEAKER: I attended
one of those.
And I thought it was
interesting, because we just
assumed that with this
pop-up at Frame, that we were
going to have a table for four.
And it was a happy
surprise that when we went,
it was family-style seating.
So we were seated at a
table with like 15 people.
And we had a chance to get
to know a bunch of people
and talk about
the food together.
So I loved that concept
and what that was.
BRAD GREENHILL: So yeah.
It was very much after the fire,
I felt more like a FEMA officer
than like a chef, you know?
But the community was absolutely
amazing, just so supportive,
everything from chef friends
hiring some of my kitchen
people, even though they knew
it was going to be temporary,
or hiring servers, or whatever.
And so it was great.
SPEAKER: I think that's
the magic of Detroit.
You won't find
another city where
people are willing to help each
other more in circumstances
like that.
BRAD GREENHILL: Yeah.
And I think the fact that
there was this public sort
of rallying around our staff
that it influences places
like Philly or Chicago
or something else.
Other people see
that, and it's hard
not to get swept up in that.
SPEAKER: Yeah, in the community.
BRAD GREENHILL: Yeah.
And I think people
can relate to it.
You know, they go
to work every day
and they're like, if my place
burned down, what would I do?
CHRISTINA PONSARAN: That
was certainly the mentality
that the former restaurant
group that I worked for had.
I mean, we all were very
aware that they'd also just
been nominated for
a James Beard Award.
And then just, what?
A week or two later,
a fire happened?
So the Philly community
had this whole idea
of a brother-in-arms scenario,
and wanted to do anything,
to do everything that
they could do to help.
So yeah.
SPEAKER: Tell us,
last but not least,
because I know we're
getting close on time,
tell us about the dish that
you brought here today for us.
BRAD GREENHILL: So
the dish I brought
today is called Som Tum Thai.
It's a very common--
we serve it at the restaurant,
and it's very prevalent
all over the
country of Thailand.
It's one of the few sort of
traditional dishes that we do.
In Thailand, there's probably
infinite variations on it.
Everyone has their own
sort of version of it,
depending on what region
of the country you're in.
But the basis of it is som
is sour, and tum is to pound.
So the idea is it's a generally
sour sort of salad that's
built in a mortar and pestle.
So the defining
characteristics--
sour and spicy, always.
So it's green papaya
that's been pounded
with a little bit of garlic,
Thai chilies, tomatoes,
long beans, and fish sauce,
palm sugar, little lime juice.
Normally in Thailand, you would
always find dried shrimp in it.
I like the dried shrimp in
it, but as a crowd pleaser,
we tend to take it out of there.
SPEAKER: Excellent.
I saw a lot of bowls
being filled back there.
So thank you very much.
And thank you so much
for coming in for today.
Let's get one more round
of applause for our guests
from Takoi.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]